God is a frequency it's our job to tune
in God is not a man you hear people say
reference God is him he they have this
illusion that there's this Sky daddy
with a magic wand floating around
granting wishes that just really in my
research isn't the case it's more of a
frequency a Divine frequency that is
imbued in every living thing in the
entire universe
so where did religion come along
that's a great question so in ancient
times people were more into spirituality
when we got to one of the highest
Advanced civilizations which started out
in Sumer and then migrated over into the
land of kamet before it became Egyptian
assumer Samaria yes it is Samaria yes
and when would that have been but a
tablet stayed back about six to eight
thousand years but those tablets we
discovered were recopied from even older
tablets which going back probably about
a hundred to two hundred thousand years
prior we're talking about a deep deep
Antiquity of super ancient culture even
in the Emerald Tablets when they
relocated home base to the land of kamet
and the animal tab it's just 36 000 year
old texts they rebuild the land of Kim
uh out of the mud which because there
was a great flood so we're talking about
ancient knowledge they said they rebuilt
Camp they didn't build it for the first
time they said they were going to bring
it back up to a high level of
civilization so it was already high
before the flood we're talking about
tens of thousands of years ago and so
they begin to create these Mystery
Schools uh at this dawn of this new era
36 000 years ago the gentleman who
started this his name was Thoth
t-h-o-t-h and he's known as a wisdom
keeper he's known all over the entire
world and every continent I've been to
there's a depiction of him there even in
the Outback of Australia they've got
them etched into a Petroglyph in in the
Rock okay and since it's wow the long
big nose yes exactly that that's him
he's he doesn't really have a bird head
but he he's depicted as such because the
the Ibis bird depicts bringing Darkness
to light because the beak is so long it
goes deeper down into the mud to bring
sustenance up
symbolic right symbology that's exactly
what it is but he ruled over the land of
chemet for 14 or 16 000 years roughly
thereabout according to the ancient
Egyptians and then he left there and
went to mesoamerica and kicked started
the teotiwakan civilization in Mexico
City you have till tibicon you have all
down throughout um Tulum and all the way
down to Chichen Itza that was all his
master architectural plan until tiwakan
is part of his African name which is
also known as tahuti and tiricon in
Mexico really means uh the city of
tahooty that he built out there so he
left there and that's why the pyramid
complex there mirrors the one at Giza in
Africa and Kem when you refer to Kim is
where he went next that's Egypt
that's Egypt yeah so Kim after uh Kim
fell after a golden age they fell and
when it uh came back you know they the
dogons were overthrown there and they
were moved out to Mali Africa and a new
group came in uh and that was probably
closer to one of the first dynastic
periods that started and that was still
a long long time ago but over time the
name Egypt which came out of Greece took
hold and that's the name we call it
today but the original name of the land
is chemist and so these these Mystery
Schools started and so these Mystery
Schools were to teach the spirituality
to Adept initiates and to pass it down
uh through verbal teachings and then
when some of these super Masters began
to pass away or leave or disappear
whatever you want to call it
some of these pyramid priests and Temple
priests realized the power that this
knowledge had and begin to alter and
remix it they understood the psychology
and the Neuroscience behind this and how
it could control masses of people so
they started to twist the the scripture
and twist the words
um and kind of utilize it for Darkness
instead of light and then we're able to
then put people into a box and put real
controls on them and dominate them and
secure them bringing them food bringing
them sacrifices bringing them money the
sacrifices were not for God the
sacrifices were so they can eat
they weren't going to go hunting yeah
you know what I mean a lamb sure yeah
exactly if you go to Egypt you go to all
these temples you'll find the storehouse
where all the sacrifices would be put in
salted and stored and hung and dried so
that these people can have food to eat
because they weren't going to go hunting
for anything they weren't going to grow
any crops so it was all the big scam so
religion started with Toth or was that
just because he started putting things
down on a tablet is there so this was
this was sort of the start of it
yeah so they they took his teachings his
spiritual teachings he's all about
seeking a light evading the darkness
understanding how to raise and be born
again through conscious thought the
first baptism that was taught is in the
animal tablets he talks about being
baptized via elevated Consciousness
being able to rise up to another level
and look back to see where you were
before and you'll be born again many
times in one lifetime if you continue to
ascend it had nothing to do with
splashing water and dumping your head in
the pool and all this other kind of
stuff uh that was also another Twist of
the of the information if you look at
the animal tablet so I wrote this book
called compendium of the animal tablets
which has been a bestseller worldwide
for four years it's now I've been
currently number one actually number one
out of three million books in ancient
civilizations uh in that book I put the
New Testament where Jesus is speaking
and I put both the atlanteans words from
The Emerald Tablets side by side and you
see that Jesus is literally mimicking
what he learned from the ancient mystery
schools which he learned directly from
the Egyptian mysteries from both the
atlanteans teachings so he's not saying
anything new in the New Testament all
those words that were spoken by him were
information that he was taught because
the real text is 36
000 years old and of course we know the
Bible was written between 180 to 900 a
day long after the people were long gone
so it's just a mimicking of ancient
texts and people began to take spiritual
Concepts and a lot of different
religions cropped out of his spiritual
writings that he wrote in those animal
tablets
so have you seen the the documentary
movie called zeitgeist
yes were they basic it was fascinating
the beginning is all about basically
Jesus and the 12 apostles and dying and
reborn three days later and the timing
and everything and and they overlay it
into more and more and more ancient
times and how it's the same story over
and over again so is that the is that an
archetypical archetypal thing or is that
um the same Consciousness coming back
over and over again and doing the same
thing is that someone learning from the
past why would that happen
yeah so the story kept getting Rewritten
the story did happen originally
thousands of years before Jesus was even
born and then the story kept getting
copied over and over and over the true
story of Jesus has really never
truthfully fully been read this the the
Sinai Bible is probably closest to the
truth because the Sinai Bible was
written before the King James Bible and
some of the other canonized books and
there's about 14 000 differences between
the two and one of the biggest
discrepancies is Jesus was never
crucified matter of fact
Harvard has a copy of the book of
Jesus's wife in its Seminary Library
what so most likely he got married had
kids and the Merovingian bloodline most
likely is still walking the planet till
this very very day and so I think that
those stories of the ancient situ uh you
know the ancient cultures having that
same story over and over again was just
it being copied again from culture to
culture and being re-read and the names
being suddenly changed but it happened
originally uh thousands of years prior
with horse
so did the actual actions happen again
or it's just the story being Rewritten
over and over again just a story being
Rewritten over and over again with
different names uh to the same exact
tale yeah just like if you read the Epic
of Gilgamesh you discover that's the
true story of Noah's Ark in the Bible
they copied it from the Epic of
Gilgamesh it's not two separate stories
it's the same exact story being
Rewritten
so who was Jesus then what is the story
I believe that Jesus his real name is
Yeshua first of all he was a real person
that did exist I've been to the house
where he grew up uh in Egypt because if
you remember in the Bible Jesus
disappears from the Bible at the age of
12. disappears you don't see him again
until he's 32. he's gone where does he
go the gospel of the Holy twelve which
was left out of the Bible has the answer
he goes to Egypt I've been there if you
go to Coptic Cairo you can go to the
house where Jesus and his mother lived
in there in in that area and this become
speak they turned it into like a crypt
now so you can go there you can you know
see where the bed he slept in and
everything is still there and um he was
learning the Egyptian Mysteries
from there he went all the way up into
Tibet to learn Reiki healing and Qigong
and that's been confirmed by the Dalai
Lama and then he left from there and
went down into India to learn the Mystic
Arts teaching reincarnation all the way
back to Egypt and then the Bible picks
up I call my son out of Egypt and then
you see him appear on the back of a
donkey in Jerusalem at the age of 32.
and that's where the Bible text picks
him back up is coming back in but he was
a very spiritual being he was a virgin
birth
and what's interesting is in the
Apocrypha text the text that was kept
out of the Bible you discover his
grandmother Mary's mother was also a
virgin birth
and if you look at the Sumerian Tablets
you discover that these virgin births
were not unusual they were experimenting
in these types of in vitro fertilization
techniques where they would take an egg
and put it in the womb and take it the
term not their egg another uh woman's
egg
um and they have this whole section in
Egypt called uh the hathor's temple at
dundera where they have these birthing
centers where they were doing yes I've
been there yeah the front the when you
walk into dundera the first temple on
the right
um inside the main Temple and then
there's isis's Temple behind that yes
that's it absolutely yeah well they get
that right at least they said that that
was the birthing Temple they got that
right yeah I think he's half human half
Atlantean that's my personal opinion so
if they were placing an egg inside of a
woman it wasn't hers right correct so he
was a virgin so what does his
grandmother was also a virgin birth they
were planted on this timeline for a
specific reason by the people who
control from behind the scenes which
were these they call themselves The
ordainers of Destiny in the Sumerian
Tablets they control they believe they
had the right to control Destinies on
this planet and they would they would
use this Crystal tablet to see potential
outcomes and Futures that they wanted
and they would then pick the one they
wanted to coalesce into one real outcome
and they would go behind go go ahead
putting action behind that to make that
reality come true for them
Masters at manifesting so was this
Bloodlines then
were they were they playing with
Bloodlines and the inherent skills that
these Bloodlines or these inherent
genetic
um advantages that they had was that
what they were working with to create
a superhuman you exactly right they had
prior to the flood
the Annunaki who are also the atlanteans
that's the same people the atlantine is
the civilization and Anunnaki means
those who came from Heaven to Earth so
it's like if we travel to Mars we
wouldn't say I wouldn't say I'm Billy
Carson from Boca Raton Florida I would
say I'm an Earthling right so Annunaki
is that generalized term atlantine is
the type of civilization they created so
and so
um basically what you find is that
before the flood they didn't even
interact with the hominids that were on
this planet they didn't interact with us
our cousins were here not Homo sapiens
sapiens but a different version of us
was already here
then they started tinkering because they
wanted to create a slave race of people
and then after the flood they decided to
utilize this new Tinker genetically
modified version of a homo sapien sapien
uh and they would they would create
leaders of these areas like for example
a pharaoh would be and the initial
pharaohs would be a direct bloodline of
one of these Anunnaki people in other
words it would be half human and half
Anunnaki where the term demigod comes
from in Greek and Rome and all of that
um and so they were baked that liaison
that bloodline liaison between them and
the people
As Time continued to go by and and
cultures and the way that the economics
and the civilizations and the kingship
and everything changed they began to
then for whatever reason hand-picked
specific people to do specific things
and they would then create these
genetically modified or bloodline people
Yeshua was one of them
um who I believe he was half human and
half Annunaki that's just my personal
opinion I have not read that anywhere
but that's based on what I've researched
yeah and what I know from studying
ancient cultures I believe that he was
not one he well he himself said he's not
of this world which means he's an alien
okay that's the definition it's true
it's a definition uh and so I believe
that he was a chosen one for whatever
the full mission was and I think the
real mission was to bring a certain
level of Christ to Consciousness which
existed before Jesus Christ that
terminology ever came to be Christ's
Consciousness is ancient it's super
ancient and it's a certain level of
Consciousness that a person can get to
this level where they're all knowing all
loving they're they're the epitome of
service to others and unconditional love
for for one another uh you know a real
true ascended being and Jesus never said
he was going to return He said the
Christ would return and he's talking
about the Consciousness coming back to
this planet and raising everyone up to a
higher level and bringing back a new
golden age that's a level of Justice
where you have this crystallized
Consciousness where everything you think
of is about how can I become a problem
solver I'm not a victim how can I help
someone how can I love this person
better how can I solve problems before
they happen because a genius will solve
problems before they happen so these
people were high level thinkers they'll
think into the future and think of what
all the outcomes can be and then create
Solutions before they even need them
that kind of level of thinking uh how to
heal people not no suppression of
medical technology and information and
stuff like that creating a true super
Christ civilization
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen